the opening scene features a famous
lawyer named Lauren Monroe who is
currently being presented with a deal a
million dollars in exchange for
defending a criminal in court however
her unwavering honesty and her moral
principles lead her to gracefully
decline the offer this is just one piece
of proof that Lawrence stands for
innocent people and not for monetary
gain lawyers get paid a shitload anyway
though the scene shifts to her younger
brother named William Monroe a
politician who is in an attempt to
secure the mayor position of New York
City next we are introduced to Lauren's
father Archer Monroe who is a wealthy
business figure he is currently walking
in the woods when he suddenly feels
difficulty in breathing the old man
somehow makes it to his car but he
tragically passes away during his drive
back home shortly after Lauren who is
attending a press conference receives
this news leaving her heartbroken the
scene then cuts to Archer's funeral
where Lauren and her entire family
gather to pay their respect after the
funeral the siblings have a brief
conversation during which William
reveals that their father was proud of
her they also discussed the process
aspect of shifting their mother to a new
place that's closer to them following
this Lauren walks to her father's office
and reminisces the fond memories of him
teaching her chess drawing the game
parallels to Life's complexities a few
days later the family's attorney Harold
shows up to announce Archer's will the
well designates Lauren's Mother
Catherine as the new CEO of their
company William is allocated with a sum
of 20 million dollars while Lauren due
to some reason is assigned with only one
million the remaining 50 million dollars
are stipulated for donations to the
police and medical schools afterwards
Harold goes to talk to Lauren in private
during which she hands her a package
left by her father for her inside it she
finds a USB device stick along with a
pair of keys she inserts the USB device
into her laptop and discovers a video
message from her late father in the
video he implores her to uphold a hidden
truth and also expresses remorse for not
being able to divulge it during his
lifetime the secret is you're only worth
1 20th of your brother in the next scene
a shocked Lauren decides to head into
the woods to learn about the hidden
truth but before that she is stopped by
her husband who seems to be concerned
about her well-being however she just
tells him that she's fine and that she
just needs some time alone Lauren then
Ventures into the woods where she
discovers a locked surface that
resembles an entrance using the key
provided earlier she unlocks the padlock
on it revealing a set of stairs leading
down to a basement Lauren nervously
descends into the dark bunker as she
walks inside as she comes across the
door and opens it only to discover a
restrained man though fearful she walks
closer to check on him but his sudden
movement startles her prompting her to
flee the bunker back at home Lauren
contemplates calling 9-1-1 for help but
her brother intervenes just in time he
empathizes with her over the unequal
distribution of money from their
father's will and offers to share his
portion however Lauren declines
asserting that money isn't a priority
for her later that evening Lauren gazes
at a childhood photo of herself with her
father and reflects on a past argument
that she had with him turns out that
Archer had asked her to represent his
rich friends in court a request she had
turned down due to her unwillingness to
defend criminals come on honey my friend
Bill's not really a pedo he's just
acting like one the next morning Lauren
decides to revisit the bunker this time
armed with a gun as she enters she finds
the man asleep so she discreetly takes
his fingerprints in order to identify
him just then the man opens his eyes
prompting her to retreat in haste she
returns after a while with a face mask
and asks his name surprisingly the man
knows every detail about Lauren and her
family including her birthday her
brother's name and even her marriage
against her father's wishes convinced by
his familiarity Lauren takes off her
mask and queries him again instead of
answering the man questions whether she
is a good person upon her affirmation he
urges her to release him because that is
what a good person would do Lauren
however remains skeptical suspecting
that he must have committed a grave
offense to Warren his imprisonment she
tries to understand the situation but
the man firstly demands for a luxurious
meal including potatoes steak Caesar
salad chocolates Goldwater cigarettes
and a bottle of sky alongside the
request for a shave Lauren threatens to
leave him confined for a lifetime but he
knows that her conscience won't allow
her to do so knowing that he has the
upper hand she decides to meet his
demands and gives him a razor before
departing Upon returning home Lauren
scans the fingerprints and sends them to
her family friend detective Emilio
Sanchez asking him to run a check on it
as soon as possible after this she
purchases all the items the man had
demanded and returns back to the bunker
since the man is provided with such
delicious food after many years of
confinement he digs it all up with tears
of joy Lauren offers him a chocolate bar
which makes him even more emotional the
man recounts how her father would offer
him a square piece of chocolate once a
year while leaving the rest untouched on
the Shelf to taunt him after devouring
all the food he finally reveals himself
as Morgan Warner he also grabs her hand
and then apologizes saying it's been a
long time since he had human contact
following this Morgan begins to unravel
his backstory disclosing that he had
crossed paths with archer three decades
earlier and form to Quick friendship as
they shared similar tastes in gambling
money and women their bond eventually
LED them to become business partners
according to Morgan one midnight Archer
was drunk driving while he was in the
passenger seat tragedy struck when
Archer struck a pedestrian resulting in
his immediate demise Morgan wanted to
call the police but Archer insisted on
disposing of the body believing that it
was an accident when the two got into an
argument Archer locked him up in this
very bunker additionally Morgan
discloses Archer's affair with a woman
named Sophia who had everything that
Catherine lacked as a result of this
Archer used to refer to her as his Gypsy
Rose Lauren doesn't believe in his words
so in order to back up his claims Morgan
gives her Sofia's address and urges her
to check it herself he also asks her to
verify with Harold who has been with
archer for years enraged Lauren walks
away and she is clearly unable to
process all of these Revelations
regardless she somehow manages to remain
calm she then contacts Emilio tasking
him with verifying the background of a
certain Morgan Warner following this she
drives towards the provided address and
meets Sophia when asked about her
connection with her father Sophia
responds that she met archer in a poker
game did she say poker
as the two continue chatting Lauren
notices a photograph of a young boy
prompting her to ask about him in
response Sophia reveals a startling
truth the boy is her son Alex who also
happens to be Lauren's half-brother
overwhelmed by all of this Lauren leaves
with tears in her eyes later on she
visits Harold's office and unleashes her
fury on him for hiding such a big secret
from the family in response Harold says
that it's his responsibility to maintain
confidentiality Lauren then asks about
any additional hidden information to
which he says that there's nothing else
that could harm her he also claims that
he'll still keep the rest of the
information hidden suggesting that she
move on subsequently Lauren goes to her
mother and inquires if she's familiar
with Morgan Warner however the name
doesn't trigger anything as she has no
idea then William enters appearing to be
stressed when questioned he says that he
is losing votes despite doing everything
he can William then urges Lauren to join
the campaign rally due to her reputation
for honesty to which she hesitantly
agrees on the same night Lauren again
goes to the bunker aiming to uncut cover
more insights she asks about the
whereabouts of the pedestrian's body
that her father had buried responding to
this Morgan proposes a deal he'll take
her there only if she'll Grant him
Freedom thereafter although reluctant at
first Lauren agrees and they venture
outside Morgan's emotions surge as he
steps out of the bunker after such an
extended period he cannot believe that
he has finally managed to get out in the
next scene Lauren follows Morgan's
directions and drives towards the woods
after a while they come across the
burial site and she immediately starts
digging her fears are soon confirmed
when she unearths a human skull
validating Morgan's claims overwhelmed
Lauren re-burries The Remains and
returns him to the bunker she then
orders him to Don his metal collar again
but he begs her not to betray him citing
her identity as an honest lawyer he
tells her not to replicate her father's
cruelty Morgan also voices his own
suffering recounting that he was unable
to attend his mother's funeral due to
his confinements he begs her to let him
spend his remaining years in peace
vowing to disappear from their lives
without causing any harm but despite his
heartfelt explanation Lauren he wasn't
sure about anything anymore apologizes
and departs afterwards she calls the
detective to ask if he got any
information regarding Morgan Warner but
the latter says that it might take a few
more days I can't believe this guy's not
suspicious the following day Lauren
visits her brother's office seeking
guidance and pretending that it's for
her court case she presents a
hypothetical scenario asking what he
would do to someone who possesses all
the secrets and also poses a threat in
response William offers two options
disposing of the person's body in a
river or paying the threat to disappear
forever this guy was born to be a mayor
after careful consideration Lauren heads
back to the bunker with a bag and makes
Morgan promise that he'll vanish forever
once he does she instructs him to
prepare for his departure assuring that
he'll be freed that night following this
Lauren approaches Harold asking him to
arrange one million dollars into private
jet for the person her father had
wronged despite Harold's inquiry into
the motive she opts not to disclose it
later is Morgan readys to leave Lauren
him if her father had mentioned anything
about her he reveals that Archer was
very proud of his daughter but he didn't
like the fact that she opposed his
friends at this point Morgan reveals
another secret her brother William has
been bribing the union Representatives
enraged Lauren immediately heads to her
brother's office and confronts him in
response the latter admits that it is
important to bribe for advancing in rank
he asserts that even their father had
resorted to bribery in order to secure
her position as a district attorney
hearing all this an enraged Lauren slaps
his ass and walks away warning him not
to deceive her again in the next scene
Morgan finally leaves the bunker taking
a chess piece as a Memento as he steps
outside he inhales the fresh air and
experiences a sense of Liberation Lauren
then escorts him to the private jet
where Harold provides him with new
identification cards and briefs him on
his account funds as Harold and Morgan
bored the jet Lauren drives back to the
bunker to clean the place during this
time she discovers a bottle of poison
beneath the bed however she doesn't
react deeming that everything is over
now on the other hand Emilio locates
Morgan's file and delivers it to
Lauren's residence in the evening
Catherine arrives home and opens the
package a few moments later Lauren
enters the room and sees her mother
looking at her package scared Catherine
expresses her concern asking why Lauren
has a picture of Carson Thomas Lauren
clarifies that his actual name is Morgan
and proceeds to truthfully disclose that
her father had confide him in the bunker
for an extended period in response
Catherine unveils a shocking Revelation
the man is in fact a ruthless serial
killer Catherine asks where he is right
now to which Lauren tells her that she
released him in a state of panic Lauren
rushes to the airport only to discover
the lifeless bodies of Harold and the
pilot she soon realizes that Morgan is
now after her mother Lauren then speeds
back home and freaks out when she
doesn't find Catherine there terrified
she rushes to the bunker and finds her
mother lying down unconscious while she
checks on her mother Morgan shows up
from the shadows and plunges the area
into darkness by switching off the
lights he then launches a sudden attack
and ties her up upon regaining
Consciousness Morgan discloses the
actual truth that he was the one to
administer the poison on her father that
ultimately claimed his life he also
recounts the night when he gave a pill
to Catherine and forced himself on her
Archer spotted him doing so and as a
result he drove Morgan to the bunker on
their way Morgan distracted Archer
resulting in a collision with a
pedestrian further Revelations indicate
that Morgan was the one who buried the
body despite Archer's objections when
Morgan opted to pin the entire blame on
Archer the latter retaliated by
physically subduing him and confining
him to the bunker after hearing all of
this Lauren tries to sway him assuring
that she'll help him with Justice for
whatever her family did to him
throughout the years however Morgan
asserts that he just wants revenge
expressing his desire to make them
endure the same misery that he suffered
for three decades he also unveils his
strategy to destroy the family's
reputation by exploiting the secrets he
holds regarding each and every member in
a dramatic twist he finally reveals
himself to be Lauren's biological father
leaving her stunned as all of this is
happening Catherine who has come back to
her senses grabs the gun from the ground
and shoots him in the head ultimately
killing him the movie ends as the mother
and daughter doused the bunker with
gasoline and burn it to the grant
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching